If you were kidnaped and forced to play brutal
death games every night, what would you do?
I'm here to break down the mistakes made,
what you should do, and how to beat the death
games in Alice in Borderland.
This kid is about to realize that danger is around
every corner.
This spiky haired student, Arisu,
wakes up on an empty beach with two other friends.
They find themselves inside an overgrown city
where there are no signs of human life.
Searching a convenience store, the reality begins
to sink in that they're in some sort of dream.
Or so they think.
Arisu tells the others that they've now
got the freedom to do whatever they want.
But all this freedom will come at a deadly price.
Later that night, the smoker Karube, begins
to worry that this dream isn't going to end.
He urges the others to start taking the situation
seriously and stop the underage drinking.
There's no dream. They're far away from home
and they need to get back.
That's when he hears something
in the distance and realizes that they aren't
the only ones in this empty city. OK.
If being in an abandoned city
sounds like a good idea, it may not seem so fun
when we realize there's no Internet now.
There's not much
we can do about waking up kidnaped.
We have no idea where the hell we are,
and there's a good chance that the other people
are going to try and hunt us down
if other Japanese death games in general
are anything to go by.
However, we first noticed that
right before we suddenly appeared here,
there was a blast emitted from those fireworks
that seemingly blinded us for a period of time.
However, we can clearly see now
and seemingly have no retinal damage,
which means that the blast we saw
was clearly not some type of explosive ordinance.
Since the blast from a one megaton
explosion would be bright enough to blind anyone
who looks at it within a 53 mile radius,
because these kids were clearly
within that radius, it's safe to say that
what they saw was clearly something else entirely.
And also, we have no burns and are not suffering
from any type of acute radiation poisoning either,
which if this scenario was caused by an explosion,
we likely would have at least felt something
burning on our skin by now.
This means that putting aside any alien abduction
type crap, someone has put us here.
At least that is what I would assume
based on all the current factors presented.
This means that the only chilling I'd be doing
would be to crack open a cold one while we try
and get to the bottom of this as soon as possible,
because I doubt
anyone would kidnap us into having a good time
unless that spot was in Bangkok, Thailand.
And in that case, I would
simply have called for help instead.
Or maybe I would.
Yeah, probably not. Now, using regular survival
tips as a guessing guide.
We can try our best to survive
as long as possible.
The first thing we should do
is stock up on as much water as we can.
Luckily for us, Japan's
tap water is completely safe to drink.
In fact, it's some of the cleanest in the world.
The next thing we should do is to look for food.
Japan is a country known
for having large amounts of processed food,
meaning the preservatives in said food should mean
that eating out won't be too difficult.
Now that our basic essentials are sorted,
we still need to find out where the hell we are
and again, we seem to be fine
from a radiation standpoint, at least for now.
But I would strip my boys down to their skivvies,
I mean underwear and check for any and all
rope burns consisting of redness, irritation
or bleeding on the skin to indicate
if we were about at any point
during our time while unconscious,
because either we've been kidnaped by some creep-o
abducted by aliens,
or we are in some sick form of web purgatory.
And if that's the case,
that means we're already dead.
The boys find themselves at an overnight market
excited by all the amazing stalls
available inside.
They notice a booth in the middle of the market
mentioning that four entries have been confirmed
over the loudspeaker worried Karube tells
the others to leave before anything bad happens,
but that's when this mysterious lady interrupts
to warn him to not step outside.
These kids look gullible as hell, and she comments
that they must be new around here.
She says that the world they're in is very real
and death is around every corner.
She flicks the kids cigaret out of the market,
and suddenly it disintegrates into nothing.
The lady mentions that they're a part of a game,
and it's just about to begin.
The booth announces that the games
difficulty is set to three of clubs
and tells each person to draw one fortune slip.
If everyone draws a fortune slip,
they beat the game.
They win not to drawing a slip, though,
means that you fail before it even starts.
The students demand that the lady reveals
everything she knows.
She introduces herself
as Shibuki and tells them that the three of clubs
means that the game is less dangerous.
The lady mentions that they need to be aware
of every small detail if they want to stay
alive, confused Arisu questions her
about the rules and where the hell they even are.
The lady gets angry
and tells him to figure it out himself.
They arrive at the booth
and the smoker decides to go first.
He's given a slip that states You are the general.
The person you're waiting for is south of here.
The next person to pick is Chota.
He's given a mathematical equation
and ordered to write the answer down on this slip
at the same time.
Karube questions the lady asking her
why she's participating in another game.
She tells them that they're all
in the same position
and doesn't know what will happen
after the game is over.
But that's when Chota answers
the mathematical equation wrong.
The booth then announces that a wrong
answer will result in being shot dead.
Suddenly,
flaming arrows attack the kid and almost kill him.
Shibuki tells them she'll go
next, and Arisu freaks his shit out at her.
That's
when she mentions that there's a time limit.
If all the lamps turn off, they'll lose the game.
Okay. This is some serious business.
What we thought was a little fun game to keep us
occupied is actually going to result in our deaths
if we don't do something.
Now, looking at our options,
it doesn't seem like running is a good idea.
There's some sort of laser beam wall
covering our every direction,
and this is going to limit our escape
opportunities.
Now we know if we get the mathematical equations
wrong, there's going to be flaming arrows
ready to burn us alive
and shred us to pieces all at the same time.
Great sense. There's no friends in this game.
We should look to our buddies
and use this girl to our advantage.
We don't know her
and bringing more people along in our group
means that supplies will run out even faster.
However, what we can do is use her body
as a sort of meat shield.
She doesn't look that small of a lady,
and I'm pretty sure Johnny Depp would agree.
And that means she's perfect for us
to use her as a shield from the arrows
if we have to, of course.
Now, we might not know how to beat
the game specifically, but what we do know
is that the game will end once the lamps burn out.
The game never specifies
whether or not we can reignite them.
So let's assume that we might be able to wait
out the game until they run out of flaming arrows.
The lady did
tell us to pay attention to every small detail,
so this is probably our best chance of success.
Shibuki picks her slip
and is given another problem.
The lady tells the booth
her answer is throw, but she's completely wrong.
Suddenly, hundreds of flaming arrows
are sent in their direction.
Arisu becomes frozen with fear,
staring at a sea of death coming his way.
His buddy runs over and kicks him in the back,
telling him to grow some balls and run.
He then suddenly decides that he wants to live
and run safely to cover.
But the group
then notices that Chota is still out in the open.
He then gets struck in the calf by an arrow,
an Arisu goes to help.
But he notices the curse
slip drop right next to him.
Chota'ss leg catches on fire
and he screams out in pain.
The smoker rushes over with a pool of water
and throws it onto his screaming friend
outers, who praises his buddy for being a hero
and gets the courage
to pick out the fourth and final slip.
He draws the greatest curse, and the others
realize that they're done for others
who begins to think hard.
Looking back at all
the recent events for any clues and suddenly
he blurts out the answer as 6.9 billion.
The booth shows a number of 6.93 billion
and tells them that the answer is wrong.
But Arisu has a plan.
He turns around and tells
everyone that the question is impossible
to answer to begin with.
Something is clearly wrong.
The rules state
that they must answer the questions,
but never mentioned that it would win them
the game.
All they need to do is to avoid the arrows,
as clearly stated on every single slip
they've been given so far.
Seeing the arrows coming,
they grab cover and run as fast as possible.
The group finds A well and Karube opens it
to find nothing but dirt.
That's when he spots a tile like material
in the dirt and digs through to find a wheel.
They head underneath and the game
congratulates them for winning the three of clubs
Arisu is given a visa showing him
how many days he can stay in the desolate city
known as Borderland.
Shibuki tells them that rumor states there are
a lot more people here than they realize.
At night, they all appear in games
and your visa is extended if you win later.
Chota spots a crazy man hiding in this school.
The man blocks the door and mentions
that all his friends were killed
in the most horrifying ways possible.
Suddenly, green beams hit the city
and Arisu begins to realize the punishment
for their visas expiring.
The next day, the group shares breakfast
and enjoys a little bit of peace and quiet.
That's when Karube interrupts,
urging them to play another game tonight.
He tells them
Chota will be sitting out since he's injured,
but the others need to sharpen
their survival skills to make it out alive.
Chota then says that since he's not playing,
his visas won't be expired.
Shibuki volunteers to stay back with him,
and they agree to play another game
when he's recovered
the 2 enter the location for the second game
and see scary looking participants waiting around.
A voice announces that the game has started and a
bloodthirsty killer is somewhere in the building.
They're told the game that they're playing is tag,
and this complex is the playground.
The difficulty is revealed to be five of spades.
And this well-dressed man informs the boys
that speed based games require physical effort.
The loudspeaker informs everyone that the game
will last 30 minutes and whoever is
the killer will start hunting in 5 minutes.
The complex has one room that isn't locked,
and that's the home base of the killer.
If a player can reach the home base
within the time limit, they'll beat the game.
The game is over when the time runs out
or all the players have been killed.
Last but not least, though,
the building is surrounded by landmines
to make sure no one leaves.
Of course. OK, here we go again.
We're now completely
familiar with these types of death games
and know that some after shit is about to happen.
People are going to die,
and there's no reason to be shocked.
In fact, we need to use them to our advantage.
We should try and pick out
any gullible suckers that we can use
and add them to our group of disposable idiots.
There's some people here who are experiencing
these death games for the very first time,
which means we can use their inexperience
to help them.
If I was Arisu, I would tell the first timers
that were allowed to retry
once were killed in the game.
They've all just been transported to a random city
in the outskirts of Japan,
and I know they're probably going to believe
anything that comes out of my mouth.
This time around,
it seems like whoever's making these games
is using landmines to keep us from running away.
Really, this makes the situation
a lot easier for us to escape
rather than having instant death
laser beams all around us.
That being said,
we don't know how many landmines have been planted
or how far out of the landmines extend
or even where the hell they are.
But I think it's safe to assume
that there's a lot of them.
Let's just completely forget about the objective
of the game and try our hand at escaping.
We don't know if this Visa stuff is even real,
and it sure doesn't seem like throwing ourselves
into more death
games is the best way to stay alive.
Arisu and Karube are best off
convincing some dumb schmucks to test it out
and throw themselves out of bounds
to their purely coincidental death.
I'd use my trusty friend Karube
and tell him to lead the way as another lifeline.
However, that would it mean we're in the clear
just yet.
It's safe to assume that these game creators
have more than a few landmines
planted around the area,
which means
while other people are getting massacred,
if we can find a heavy object,
something like a fire extinguisher
which is commonly found in apartment complexes,
we could throw that off of the building as well
and on the surrounding area.
This will detonate at the land mines
and give us a clear pathway out of here, possibly.
Of course,
this isn't a foolproof method of surviving,
but thinking out of the box
is more important to it.
Our lives are on the line.
Arisu
instantly begins analyzing the situation at hand.
Suddenly they hear the sound of a door opening
and shots are fired.
They run upstairs to see two players
being brutally murdered.
The killer turns to them and starts shooting,
forcing them to run for their lives.
Arisu stops his buddy
and tells them to head another direction,
using the well-dressed man as a decoy.
And he tells
Karube to hold his breath once the killer
passes, the boys run as fast as possible away.
That's when Arisu reveals
that the killer was dragging his foot,
meaning they can move faster than him.
Arisu tells his buddy
that now's the time to find the home base.
Karube screams out to the other players,
telling them
the identity of the killer
and urges them to help each other.
However, he doesn't realize
that this is not a game of trust.
This purple haired girl tries to warn this player
about the killer, but gives up and climbs away.
Narrowly missing the machine gun.
Meanwhile, this desparate man tries
to leave the play area and gets blown to bits,
assuring the others
that there's no reason to leave yet.
Now, 10
minutes have passed and they've begun to realize
that checking each door manually is too slow.
Arisu spaces out for a second
and the killer spots them standing around.
He then hides behind the wall,
hoping that the killer only noticed his body.
Karube runs down stairs and bumps into these two
serious looking players.
They tell him that they're looking for the killer
and it's time to start running.
Karube grabs
the killer's attention, distracting him
while the others spray their fire extinguishers.
That's when they signaled to the bald man,
and he opens the elevator door
to choke him out from behind.
But suddenly the bald man is shot dead
and the killer reveals another gun,
then shoots the other man who says before he dies,
he should have known there was another gun
and the killer head straight for Karube, Arisu
stops him running away and calls out for his buddy
putting himself in danger.
Noticing the killer coming his way,
he realizes that the man isn't after him.
He's only protecting the home base
the game of Tag is a cover up
to throw them off of the real target.
With only one minute left, Arisu knows
that the killer must be guarding the base.
That's when he sees Karubee
coming around the corner.
And a plan is put into action.
Iris, who grabs the killer's attention
while Karube sneaks up from behind.
He grabs and throws the map,
allowing Arisu to get inside.
But suddenly the horse faced killer reappears
and is about to kill him.
But this athletic girl manages to knock him down,
and they both press the buttons
and the man explodes, meaning
they've just won the second game.
Later, Karube spots this long haired man
looking around the dead bodies.
The man explains
he knows more about this game than, well,
most and tells Karube to find a working radio.
If he wants information,
the next day he finds a taxi radio
ordering everyone to find a nearby beach.
The group arrives at the next location
to find a sign for the third game.
They put on these headsets and walk inside,
looking around to see
a massive indoor nature zone.
The door's locked and a loudspeaker announces
that it's game time.
The difficulty is revealed as seven of hearts
their hardest game yet.
This time they'll be playing hide and seek.
One person will be the wolf
and the rest will be sheep.
The players must hide from the wolf site.
If they're caught, the wolf
and the sheep will switch places.
The sheep
then has 3 seconds to disappear. Shocked.
The group realizes that one of them has to die.
That's when the loudspeaker announces
that the wolf is the only winner.
Once the game is over.
The choker around the sheep's neck will explode.
The game announces
the players roles with Chota being the wolf.
Okay, this is totally messed up,
but survival of the fittest is how it goes.
Now we know the biggest mistake is by entering
another death game.
However, if I'm Arisu I'm pulling it
all the emotional heart strings of my buddy Chota
to make him look at me, even if it resorts to me
giving him a good, hard slap.
If that doesn't work, then I'm taking my buddy's
head and forcibly making him look at me.
If his eyes are shut,
I'm going to use my thumbs and pry his lids open.
Once that's sorted out, I'm running away
as far as I can to avoid looking at my friends
and reverting back to a sheep.
Survival of the fittest
is the name of the game, folks.
And while these boys have probably been my friends
for a long time,
I can always make more friends once
I'm out of here now.
Playing a game of hide
and seek in a massively huge park forest
shouldn't be that hard of a place to hide in.
There seems to be a wide variety of creeks
streams bushes that we can use to hide it.
Luckily for us, the time
limit for the game is only 10 minutes long.
That's not exactly a lot of time
for the others to find us.
This game isn't really that hard.
All you have to do is suppress your emotions
and act like a psychopath.
And imagine
if you've lived through a lifetime of trauma
knowing that you've just killed your best friends,
says this indoor forest
is home to a number of tall, sturdy trees.
We could also try our best to climb up one of them
and hold on to it for the remainder of the game.
As long as the tree is big enough and tall enough
and the foliage in the tree is thick enough,
we could even take a nap on one of the branches,
just like in The Jungle Book
while everyone else dies.
And that way no one is going to be able
to catch me and change my wolf status.
Chota is injured.
Karube is too dang heavy and she looks tired.
Clothes are going to restrict her
from any kind of climbing in general.
Shocked Arisu tries thinking of a way out
but can't come up with anything
as the wolf Shibuki here
makes the biggest mistake.
She runs off in Karube freaks out.
He pins her down to the ground and threatens
to kill her for betraying them.
Sheba, he manages to throw them off while he's
distracted and she looks up to Chota on accident.
The new wolf then runs off or orders
who runs after him.
Chota accidentally looks at him
changing the wolf one more time.
He decides to take the opportunity and tells Chota
that they're no longer friends.
With only 5 minutes left on the clock
Arisu hides in the bushes to avoid the others.
That's when short a context on the headsets
to make a dirt bag confession.
He tells them that he hooked up with Sheba
while they were gone.
shocked Arisu screams out and realizes
that the game is tearing them apart.
He walks to the front of the park
and tells them to come out
if they want to be the wolf and survive.
Arisu desperately tries looking for them.
But all the sheep agree to let him survive.
They bid him farewell as the chokers explode
on their necks leaving him as the sole survivor.
The park then bursts into flames.
An Arisu is left all alone.
He explodes in a rage and promises
to kill anyone responsible for these games.
Then the pink haired girl from earlier gives Arisu
her hand and tells him to come along if he
wants to live.